well the government jersey is
very determined to crack down on crime
not murders and rapes but anyone who
criticizes the governor of new jersey
on fox news and that would include the
people who run the attila's gym
the owners of that gym have refused to
stay closed this year in november we
spoke to the owner
ian smith so
frank and i are currently being fined
personally
governor murphy has attempted to pierce
the llc
he has fined us fifteen thousand four
hundred ninety seven dollars and seventy
six cents per day
that fine started as per day yes
well the attila's gym has not paid those
fines but the
state didn't wait around to litigate
or adjudicate they just took 170
thousand dollars
from the gym's bank account because they
can do that because they're the state
they don't have to ask permission
so we asked the state of new jersey
about this they gave us the statement
quote the state previously obtained a
judgment from the court in the amount of
134 thousand 463
dollars and eight cents which the state
intended to collect apparently the funds
were a reference
you referenced were frozen as a result
of a bank levy having been issued due to
the state's collection efforts which is
part of the enforcement of the judicial
order okay keep in mind
that all sounds very legal if you stop
paying your rent how long does it take
you
to get evicted from your apartment
probably new jersey a year or two
this happened like that they targeted
these people ian smith is one of them
he's the owner of the gym he joins us
tonight and thank you for coming on
i'm sorry about this thank you for
having me has has the murder rate
dramatically declined in say camden
i mean it seems like the state is
focusing an awful lot of resources i
think it's actually higher criticizing
them
yeah right i'm sorry i'll stop ranting
tell us what the state of affairs is
tonight
so as of yesterday morning my partner
and i checked the bank statement in the
morning
and we had no money in our bank account
uh the state emptied out every single
dollar that we have
this is in the middle of an appeals
process and ongoing litigation
in the matter of the fines and several
other matters regarding the state
including a lawsuit against governor
murphy and jill or judith person kelly
herself
this is as simple as i can put it this
is an interference with our right to
counsel
this money in our bank account does not
come from memberships we have not
charged our members
since april 1st since we originally shut
down this is donations and this is
t-shirt sales that we have used to pay
our bills
and to fight our legal battles and it is
a clear and it is a
a blatant violation of our
constitutional rights and our ability to
defend ourselves in the court of law
how long do you think they'll allow
cryptocurrency to exist
sorry just a thought probably not too
long if they can't seize it from you
no they can't and that's actually one of
the uh most frequent recommendations for
people who want to continue to donate is
to set up a crypto account
yeah while you still can uh so now that
they've taken all your money and you
can't afford legal defense
what's your path forward
uh we will be we will be fundraising we
we put out a video last night explaining
the problems that we're facing and we
put out a call to help to
to the many people who have supported us
from the beginning and and the many
people who have
learned about our story along the way
and we've got a
450 t-shirt orders to fill and a lot of
donations coming in so
from now on we're going to pull all of
our money out and we're going to just
go at it in cash and write checks as we
go um there will be no money in our bank
accounts and
we'll continue to fight this no matter
what
i just want to very quickly remind our
viewers with two things you haven't
spread covert to anybody
and i'm reminding the goldman sachs guy
who runs your state you're being
punished for trying to keep people
healthy and trim
in the middle of a pandemic that kills
people who are overweight and out of
shape
doing more than he has to save people's
lives and of course you're being
destroyed for it ian smith i appreciate
and i would just
thank you very much tucker thank you
well